vous nous avez demandé lesquels parmi
les logo sur les emballages de produits
de la mer nous aide vraiment à faire des
choix responsables
l'éco certification vise à assurer la
durabilité des activités de la pêche en
fonction de critères objectifs et
universel or biais peut remplir ces
conditions une allégation comme amis des
dauphins ne reposent généralement pas
sur des données solides des labels comme
pêche fiables ou encore de sources
responsables sont des auto proclamation
sans vérification externe créé par
certaines compagnies d'autres étiquettes
représente davantage des programmes de
recommandations que des certifications
c'est la certification msc qui à ce jour
demeure la plus fiable et la plus
rigoureuse
elle repose sur une évaluation
indépendante tête par des scientifiques
l'analyse tient compte de l'état des
stocks des méthodes de pêche et de leurs
impacts sur les écosystèmes